so yesterday we pointed out that Joe
Biden is a crook today the hits just
keep on coming as Biden's White House is
revealed as having abused its power to
pressure Facebook to censor
us
little me can you imagine that little of
me whom everybody loves so the White
House we know the White House doesn't
like us we know that Facebook doesn't
like us we had a sense that Facebook was
censoring and suppressing us now we have
the proof this is care of Jim Jordan
Facebook files this is a note from Rob
Flaherty who was Biden's White House
digital director to Facebook from Rob if
you were to change the algorithm so that
people were more likely to see the New
York Times The Wall Street Journal any
authoritative news source over daily
wire
Tommy Lauren polarizing people you
wouldn't have a mechanism to check the
material impact yeah we want New York
Times we want Wall Street Journal we
want anything other than daily wire we
hate daily wire suppressed daily wire
this is
as clear a violation of the First
Amendment as it gets you know me I'm
very cautious about saying such and such
is a First Amendment violation the first
amendment has all sorts of constraints
put on it but when the White House
is pressuring the company that controls
the Public Square to censor us specific
people
that's it even if it's not the
government itself doing the censoring
even if the government just uses a
private company semi-private company as
an instrument that is a First Amendment
violation this is not some low-level
staffer they're not going to be able to
kick this away and and say look over
there nothing to see here move along
move along this this guy Rob Flaherty
was a senior staffer in the White House
led the office of digital strategy when
he left the White House not that long
ago June 16th of this year Biden sent
out a statement a presidential statement
on how important this guy is he says uh
since day one Rob has helped us meet
people where they are keeping a constant
eye toward reaching new in different
communities and censoring people that he
doesn't like under Rob's leadership we
built the largest office of digital
strategy in history with it blah blah
blah I'm grateful to Rob for his service
over the last three years the
integration of the digital team into our
senior White House leadership shows just
how important Rob's team is for our
daily engagement with the American
people and suppressing conservatives
daily engagement for the American people
this is a top advisor to the president
did Joe Biden not know about this was
this not a strategy that was that was
agreed upon by the White House senior
staff was there some Rogues I don't
think so I don't think so so what does
this do I'm sick and tired of
discovering things and discovering how
unfair the system is and how there's two
tiers of justice and then nothing
happens that drives me crazy Republicans
are really really good at pointing out
injustices and we're really really bad
at doing anything to fix them so I'm not
pointing this out to suggest that
anything is actually going to be done or
this guy Rob or Joe Biden or anyone's
going to be able to account for it
the reason that this strikes me
other than explaining why our Facebook
views dropped off pretty significantly
all at once when Biden took office the
reason this sticks out at me is it
raises an important question the
question is not why are they censoring
conservatives we know that because they
hate us and they're Lawless the question
is not why are they breaking the law we
know they don't really have any respect
for the law and they think that the law
is nothing but the Caprices and
arbitrary whims of however they're
feeling that day that's how they operate
nothing new there the real question is
why is this coming up now
why is the liberal establishment
allowing this information to seep out
now and the next question is
if one concludes that it's because the
liberal establishment is slowly giving
up on Joe Biden they think Joe Biden is
going to lose to the likely nominee
Donald Trump they think that maybe they
could begin to replace him then the
question is who replaces Biden if he's
too weakened to run I'm Michael Moses
Michael nols Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show speaking of
authoritative sources
a porn lady has gone viral for giving
advice on marriage and why it's very
important for young women to divorce
their husbands we'll get to to that
brilliant advice from from a born Lady
first though
more people trying to censor us
and me specifically not us broadly I I
had quite a semester this past semester
you know I speak on a lot of college
campuses every semester and this year we
had two really big ones one was at
Pittsburgh where antifa tried to blow me
up the other one was at the University
of Buffalo and the University of Buffalo
was an earlier speech where the
university SUNY the entire State
University of New York school system
tried to shut this thing down
politicians tried to shut this thing
down didn't work the first amendment
demanded that I'd be permitted to speak
in the University of Buffalo students be
allowed to invite me but then after that
the school said okay young America's
Foundation you yaphers on campus
your Club is gone
you're you don't get a club anymore
because you had the audacity to invite
Michael Knowles and he's a he's a meanie
and he doesn't agree with our crazy
ideologies so your Club is gone okay
hope it was a good event by no more
conservative representation on campus so
what happened yaf sued said this is a
First Amendment violation this is this
is completely unfair and unjust and
looked like things were going pretty
well for the conservatives until
University of Buffalo tries another way
to get rid of the club
the University of Buffalo is now
requiring that when clubs sign up to
become officially University registered
clubs that they surrender their right to
file a lawsuit against the university in
order to maintain Club Status it's
because they just don't give up
they're saying okay you're not allowed
to be a conservative at Buffalo we're
going to get rid of that club so you
can't do that we're going to sue you
okay we're gonna pass a new rule you
can't ever sue us
you can't okay we're and we're going to
pass a new rule you're never allowed to
question the rule that says that you
can't sue us when we kick you on campus
for being conservative
we're going to pass another rule about a
rule about a rule about a rule that says
that if you've ever owned a Maga hat in
your life you have to be in prison
that's well we'll get to that in a
second
they never give up
the libs even if we win in court even if
we pass a law even if we conservatives
win an election they will never give up
I suppose that's the way politics is
you're never totally lost in politics
because you've never totally won
anything
but the libs are particularly persistent
here they won't accept their losses lick
their wounds and move on they're just
going to keep pummeling ahead they will
not allow this group back on campus no
matter what some judge says no matter
what the school rules say no matter what
the First Amendment says
they won't give up they're Shameless
about it
you want to see how Shameless they are
Secretary of State Anthony blinken one
of the
least reputable people in the Biden
Administration which is really saying
something he just comes out with a
straight face and complains about
Nations around the world who are holding
political prisoners
the state Department's latest human
rights report contains evidence of more
than 65 countries holding political
prisoners
so many of these individuals are their
country's best and brightest hope for a
future that's marked by democracy and
respect for human rights
through imprisoning political prisoners
autocrats are quashing democratic hopes
and ambitions
that's why it's important that all
countries stand firmly against the
Detention of political prisoners no
matter where they are held and work
together to free them
let me share a few ways that we do this
and urge other countries to join us
we call for the release of political
prisoners
we meet with their families and
colleagues we monitor trials we publish
reports to share information about
individuals and their cases can you can
you stop right there you know what you
know and you know what else they do they
lock up Midwestern grannies who had the
audacity to go into the capital to
express their support of Donald Trump
that's how we
that's how we in the United States
deal with this terrible issue of
autocrats imprisoning political
dissidents we raise awareness and we
give speeches and we call out those 65
countries around the world and we lock
up the horn hat guy for 41 months in
solitary confinement because he took
some pictures and got a private tour of
the Capitol wait what
wait hold on how many so it's a some
Midwestern grannies there's that nice
Florida guy remember he was holding
Nancy Pelosi's lecture and yeah they
threw him in the can the horn hat guy
who was welcomed around the capitol
escorted by police so they threw him in
the can for 41 months why what crime did
they commit
did they burn the country down like the
blmers no if they had done that they
would have gotten completely off the
hook not even a slap on the wrist
did they Loot and Riot and kill people
like the BLM people no
no they didn't do that they just
supported Donald Trump
for which people are still today being
indicted and prosecuted
people in Michigan were just ordinary
Republicans who had questions about the
2020 election being brought up on
charges
looking at a very long time in prison
that's how we deal with with this awful
scourge of political prisoners
no one ever sees himself
as the bad guy
which we'll talk about in a second when
you want to talk to your friends you got
to check out pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com Knowles you know a company
is looking out for you when they
actually upgrade your service and don't
charge you for it this is great news for
new and current Pure Talk customers pure
talk just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile hotspot with no price
increase whatsoever if you've considered
pure talk before but have not made the
switch take a look again for just 20
bucks a month you will get unlimited
talk text and now 55 zero percent more
5G data plus their new mobile hotspot
this is one of the many reasons I love
pure talk it's veteran owned they only
hire the best customer service team
located right here in the US of a that
alone is worth the switch most families
are saving almost a thousand dollars a
year while enjoying the most Dependable
5G Network in America remember you vote
with how you spend your money so stop
supporting woke wireless companies that
don't support you when you go to
puretalk.com Knowles you will save an
additional fifty five zero percent off
your first month because they value you
go to puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk
Wireless for Americans by Americans the
United States has political prisoners
I guess basically every country in the
history of the world has had some
political prisoners at some point
but they never seem to be all that
honest about it
if you if you go to Russia today there's
a political prisoner the leader of the
opposition uh what is that guy's name I
forget he's vaguely pro-western uh he's
been locked up for quite some time he's
a political prisoner because he's the
leader of the opposition against
Vladimir Putin
uh
navalny Alexi navalny but if you asked a
Russian who supports the regime if you
asked a member of the regime why is
Alexian evolny in prison they'd tell you
why because I'm sure he committed some
crime you can indict a ham sandwich
if if you ask a liberal today or even
some sadly naive conservatives does the
United States have political prisoners
they'll tell you no no absolutely not
that's something that awful terrible
dictator autocrats do say okay well what
about the January sisters they'll say oh
no they they
we're insurrectionists
good point out well they were never
charged with an insurrection
oh yeah well they killed people you
pointed out no they never they didn't
kill anybody the only person was killed
in the political violence that day was
one of the Trump supporters killed by a
trigger happy cop say well I'm sure they
did something and I'm sure they did do
something they were charged with
trespassing they were charged with
disrupting an official proceeding they
were there were crimes they were charged
with that doesn't mean they're not
political prisoners
to have the Biden Administration which
has clamped down on political dissonance
and political uh opposition
in an unprecedented way in the United
States I was going to say in a way that
we haven't seen since Woodrow Wilson in
a way that we haven't seen since since
Eugene Debs the Socialist candidate for
president was imprisoned but it's it's
worse than that we've never seen a
former president imprisoned while he is
the leader of the opposition while he's
the chief political rival to the sitting
president we've never seen anything like
that
Before You Accuse Me Take a look at
yourself guys
absolutely no credibility whatsoever to
talk about political prisoners
now
speaking of bad guys there's a porn lady
her name is Mia Khalifa
Mia Khalifa is a political activist but
she's also a porn lady I don't know if
she still does porn or if she only
previously did porn but
she has all sorts of opinions that are
not very good and she spouts off on
politics sometimes and she's just given
her worst opinion yet this is her
opinion on divorce
oh we're comparing stats baby girl
doesn't know that I am Tom Brady at this
game
married at 18 divorced at 21 second
marriage married at 25 divorced at 28.
third engagement engaged at 29 ended it
at 30 but I kept the ring I'm still
keeping Tom Brady on his toes
we should not be afraid to leave these
men we are not stuck with these people
marriage is not a sanctimonious thing it
is it is paperwork it's something it's
it's it's a commitment you make to
someone but if you feel like
you're not getting anything from that
commitment and you're trying you gotta
go you gotta go you have to go I know
it's difficult to fill out paperwork and
to make appointments and to do all of
these things but this is your life do
you want to be stuck with someone
period
so not great advice
generally speaking probably not the
wisest thing to take advice on marriage
from a prostitute or or even forget the
prostitute for a second probably best
not to take advice on marriage from
people who have had multiple failed
marriages
I'm not knocking her we live in a messed
up culture she's made all sorts of bad
decisions but we also live in a very
pornographic culture that just seduces
women into this kind of a lifestyle you
see this especially with the
democratization of porn through things
like only fans you see it in the Andrew
take case
Andrew Tate whatever charges he was
brought up on in Romania I don't even
really care
he's a pimp he's a pimp who brags on
camera about seducing women which in a
wiser older age seduction was considered
not only
not less severe than than a physical
violation like rape but actually more
egregious because while rape violates
the body
rather egregious seduction violates the
soul and the intellect so now we just
think that's all fine because our only
moral Criterion for political judgment
is consent
but no we live in a culture that seduces
these young girls into all of this
nonsense in in the way that we see
particularly with Andrew Tate who says
oh yeah I trick these girls into falling
in love with me and then I'd pimp them
out and have them do tricks so I'd make
a lot of money and then I'd rip them off
and put them in a house in Romania and
have film videos of themselves and he's
bragging about it at least you see that
kind of transparency I mean the more I
to paraphrase nor McDonald the more I
hear about the Sandra Tate fella the
more he sounds like a real jerk but our
whole culture does that it's not just
Andrew Tate he's just one guy it's the
whole culture seduces women into porn
and so I'm really not knocking this out
Mia Khalifa but
this is a weird thing in society today
where we
we take advice from people who have no
credibility on these issues we've just
lost our sense of authority
even you see this in the reflexive
response against authoritarianism on the
left and on the right we just hate all
authority and so we just we recoil into
our own individualism we we exalt
individual conscience and judgment above
all things this is a product of the
Enlightenment the liberal age it's a
product that we see on the left it's a
product that we see on the right but
it's wrong there are legitimate
authorities
to whom we should listen
our parents uh wise teachers the
Traditions that have endured throughout
the ages the moral law the natural law
the the church the
true there is Authority that we ought to
recognize Authority is not a bad thing I
know the a word is very nasty in our
modern culture but Authority is not a
bad thing and you can't escape it you're
going to make a judgment somewhere so
either you're going to follow good wise
just prudent legitimate authorities or
you're going to listen to your own
extremely imperfect
moral reasoning with your very imperfect
faculties of reason
or you're going to listen to people who
have no credibility at all
like porn people
on marriage and
political Crux like the bidens on
corruption and our sacred democracy in
our justice system and so on and so
forth you're not going to fix this
problem at the very basic political
level of marriage or at the macro
political level of the state by
neglecting by denying legitimate
Authority now speaking of people who
don't have authority on lots of things
Neil deGrasse Tyson
the popular
edutainment scientist guy
he has just come out in support of a
thing that I'm not allowed to talk about
on YouTube
[Music]
sometimes this is described as people
who have credibility and Authority in
one Realm
creeping out of their realm of authority
and credibility and speaking to things
that they don't know anything about
often Noam Chomsky is accused of this
because he's a really interesting
linguist and important linguist but then
he spats off on the Vietnam War he
doesn't know anything about Vietnam and
people say oh you're reaching too far
you see this especially with someone
like a Sam Harris who maybe possesses
some kind of expertise they spounce off
on politics he doesn't know anything
about it I think the problem goes deeper
than that my issue is not that the
scientists aren't sticking to science my
my issue is with science capital S
entirely I think the the world view that
has come to predominate since the
Scientific Revolution was always going
to end in this kind of incoherent
nonsense even from otherwise potentially
intelligent people it's not a good look
when you want to look good you got to
check out gen yourself right now go to
geniusell.com Knowles kwles is that a
dark spot on your face is it is that
what I see over there is it still
bothering you what about those liver
spots on your hands neck and chest well
now
you can watch them disappear safely and
quickly in just three minutes
introducing the genucel Dark Spot
Corrector the three-step three-minute
dark spot luxury system does exactly
what it sounds like by using their
Crystalis
microdermabrasion before the Dark Spot
Corrector and finishing with a touch of
collagen building genucel 15 you will
see the dark spots disappear before your
very eyes instantly smoothly luxuriously
I also just love this company because
the owner is a Founder rather is a
Coptic Christian who left Egypt for the
American dream head on over to
geniusell.com
Knowles order the new dark spot
treatment system today say goodbye to
those pesky spots tomorrow
genucell.com
Knowles you can get your genucel bags
and puffiness serum also included right
now in geniusell's most popular package
for seventy seven zero percent off
genucel.com
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Robert Paul gas who says that Sikh guy
who dished out that beating is going to
get a lasting lesson there's no way the
libs are just going to let a video of
that being done to a black man go viral
without punishment for the vigilante
Maybe
certainly if the seat guy in the shop
had been beating the the robber with a
stick if if he had been a white man he
would already be behind bars he'd
probably be at Guantanamo Bay being
tortured but because he is I think
sufficiently Brown sufficiently an
immigrant sufficiently religiously
diverse he's got the turbanon I I think
he might get away with it I don't I
haven't checked the hierarchy of race
and religion recently but I think
I think he might get away with it it was
a very satisfying video in that we keep
seeing these robbers come in and just
commit all sorts of injustices and they
get away with it you heard the guy in
the video he said oh you got to wait
till the cops get here or you're not
allowed to do anything and that would
have worked on Americans who know how
the liberal establishment works but this
immigrant guy the sea guy said no I
think I'm going to just pick up a stick
and just start caning him until he gives
me my property back really really smart
stuff
when a Neil deGrasse Tyson or any of
these people who say that they're very
scientific
when they go off and blabber about
nonsense
that's not
just a flaw in their character it's not
just an expression of Pride it's not
just them going beyond their scientific
expertise it's a problem of science
because the scientific worldview
says that
all we can ever really know is physical
and it implies that reality itself is
fundamentally physical maybe there are
other aspects of reality illusory or
otherwise but fundamentally what reality
is about is atoms and molecules and
physical stuff
and that isn't true that's false and
that that view the Scientific Revolution
worldview pushes out
all other more important modes of
thinking and it's why even the the
really smart people in the lab coats are
pretty much always wrong about
everything they might be right about a
few particular things
sometimes but ultimately in the big
questions they're wrong
you see this throughout the academy on
the exactly the same issue Richard
Dawkins
who's I guess a sharp guy within his
field of biology maybe I don't know I've
never been a huge Dawkins fan uh Dawkins
so he always likes to spout off on
religion and he never sends all that
smart doing it even though he's an
Oxford Dawn type of fellow but but now
he's spatting off on
and
[Music]
then
it's not just that these guys are
stepping out of their comfort zone their
whole world view is wrong they just
don't have authority they've got about
as much Authority on these matters as
Mia Khalifa does on marriage
speaking of a lack of consensus
there is a report out from New York
Times Siena College
that it might be the most shocking poll
in presidential politics that we've seen
yet it's not about Trump or DeSantis or
Vivek or even Biden
it's about Kamala
the strongest argument against
impeaching Joe Biden has always been
Kamala Harris
according to this poll is more popular
among Democrats than Joe Biden
according to this New York Times Siena
College poll
26 percent say they would be
enthusiastic about Kamala Harris at the
top of the presidential ticket compared
with only 20 percent who say they're
enthusiastic about Biden at the top of
the presidential ticket so this again
ties in with what we're talking about
right at the top of the show more and
more evidence not of Biden being a crook
we've known that all the time not of Joe
Biden being a marionette held up by
strings who doesn't know what day it is
we've known that the whole time it's
evidence of the Democrats souring on
Biden when you get a Maureen Dowd column
in the New York Times saying Joe Biden's
a mean guy is cruel he's heartless
because he won't acknowledge his
grandkid that's a sign of that when you
get leaks from the White House damaging
leaks from the White House that's a sign
of it when you get these polls saying oh
Kamala she's actually
she's more popular Democrats are more
enthusiastic about her now I don't
believe this Poll for a second by the
way Kamala Harris is a singularly bad
retail politician the only reason that
that Democrats might think that they're
enthusiastic about her right now is
because they basically never see her
Kamala Harris pops up once a month she
gives some babbling incoherent speech
makes Neil deGrasse Tyson look like he's
reciting Shakespeare and she she cackles
a little bit and then she goes back into
the Shadows
this is just like Hillary Clinton
who had really good poll numbers until
she hit the campaign Trail and people
remembered that they don't like her
this is this is true of all sorts of
politicians who when they're out of the
public eye their approval numbers
increase but the minute you see them
again you forget that you don't like
them complete BS Democrats might have
soured on Joe they might think they've
got a better shot but in reality Kamala
Harris has a way lower chance of being
elected president than Joe Biden does in
2024. speaking of unpleasant women the
gal who's playing Snow White or as I now
call her sand taupe sand beige the snow
the snow white who is upending all the
traditions of Snow White uh she's she's
got another another viral hit
so she's out there protesting with sag
after the actors Union and she's saying
you know I need a better contract why do
I need a better contract because I'm
working this terrible hard job and I'm
not being paid enough for it yeah I'm
the star in the new Snow White movie but
if I've got to go out there and wear
that stupid dress I gotta go wear that
dress all day long I got to be on set
and I gotta dress up and play pretend
and I have to be a little girl's dream
and I need to make believe for my job
and I need to receive adulation and
praise and lots of money
if I have to do that damn it I'm gonna
make even more money
boy my life is so hard
a person with that attitude is incapable
of happiness
Neil deGrasse Tyson misinterprets the
meaning of the phrase Pursuit of
Happiness that gal should she should
just give it up if that's going to be
her attitude she will never achieve
happiness
some people
can be perfectly happy in even the worst
of circumstances and other people
can not be happy even in the best think
about what she's saying she's not saying
I gotta go you know to the coal mines
all day long
she has what is considered the most
glamorous fun silly light job in the
world she's not only in entertainment
she's an actress she's not only an
actress she's a successful actress
she's not only a successful actress
she's playing a Disney princess
the most famous one of all
and she's complaining about it
we all do this from time to time even
even I do it or we just oh I'm just so
um so frustrated I'm really angry ah my
job is hard
you need a gut check you need to that
take that as a as a warning because this
woman every time she opens her mouth she
says something more offensive than the
last time
but we all fall into that sometimes oh I
gotta take my kids to the park today I
hate
living this wonderful dream and spending
time with my precious children I oh I've
got to go do my job that pays me well
and is generally Pleasant I like my
co-workers and ah man I hate having to
do that I don't fall into that's very
easy people can complain about anything
especially on movie sets that's one of
the weird things about movies that's
people complain all the time and so no
surprise that sag after is whining about
it do not be
like that woman despite the lackluster
economy the daily wire is thriving
not only that we're hiring we are
currently looking for a production
assistant to join our fast screen
production Department believe it or not
this show does not run itself I mean I
would say I carry 97 of this show and at
least 96 of the entire company on my
shoulders by myself but there are other
people around here who also occasionally
do things behind the scenes you will
find our production team hard at work
our production assistants are key
components of a successful show we're
currently looking to add another PA to
the team if you've got production
experience thrive in a fast-paced high
demand environment and are looking to
grow your career in the field of
production apply on our careers page
today position is based in Nashville
Tennessee if you're interested in
joining our team go to dailywire.com
careersdailywire.com careers today
finally finally we've arrived at my
favorite time of the week when I get to
hear from you in the mailbag this
mailbag is sponsored by puretalk at
puretalk.com Knowles to get 55 zero
percent off your first month take it
away
hey Michael I need some help making a
life decision I'm 22 and I'm originally
from Western New York but I dropped out
of college one and a half years ago to
move to Montana I've always had a desire
to start a business and my best friend
and I since high school have been
talking about it
we now finally have the time ability and
money to get something off the ground
but it would obviously require me
leaving a good paying job and stable
life in Montana
I was already supposed to move back last
month but something in my gut told me to
stay here I can't stop second guessing
any decision I make and it's led to a
world of confusion
did I make the right choice in staying
should I move back any advice would be
helpful thanks
thanks two roads diverged in the yellow
wood and sorry I could not travel both
and be one traveler long I stood and
looked down one as far as I could to
wear it bent and the other growth then
took the other as just as fair and
having perhaps the better claim because
it was grassy and wanted where though as
for that the passing there
left them really about the same and each
that morning equally land leaves in a
step it's rod and black oh I saved the
first for another day but knowing how
whales aren't away I doubted that I
should ever come back and I shall say
this for the size somewhere ages and
ages hence two roads diverged in wood
and I
I took the One Less Traveled by and that
has made all the difference
I might not have been totally
wordperfect I memorized that poem in
high school people misunderstand the
poem because they think it's called The
Road Not Taken or The Road Less Traveled
but it's called The Road Not Taken
because
the two roads both look pretty good
they look almost indistinguishable and
how good they look and it's only ex post
facto that we say oh yeah I took the one
less traveled eye that made all the
different sigh because we met because
you can't go down two roads at the same
time and I don't know for you which one
you should go down you say you have the
ability to start a business do you I
don't know
you're quite Young
how much money do you have where'd you
get the money are you frivolously going
to squander that money away or is this
hard-earned money with a solid business
plan with something that's likely I just
don't know any of those things maybe you
don't know those answers either
are you the kind of fella who's going to
be an entrepreneur or are you more the
kind of guy who's going to work your job
and I don't know I just don't know
only you could tell me that maybe your
friends can give you some advice on that
in politics I do trust my gut very often
because I I if anything I'm a little too
risky in in my professional life I've
been in all sorts of very risky Fields
Show Business politics I've moved all
over the place
so I I'm a I I trust my gut if my gut
says hey
you should be a little more risk-averse
here is that the same for you I don't
know
uh
I think of Caleb Robinson one of the
founders of the daily wire he gave up a
pretty decent high paying job when he
had six kids to go risk it all to start
this business it's paid off very well
for him but it's a risk and you're
asking me to tell you well what's
you know what's the most prudent thing
to do
I don't know
sometimes you gotta know when to hold
them know when to fold them
they'll want to walk away when to run
I'm really quoting a lot of poetry here
today uh you just need to be prudent
about it and you need to recognize that
you might get down the road that you
follow and have regrets
and and not even know what the other the
problem is you won't even know what the
other Road looks like and you'll tell
yourself all sorts of stories but you
don't know how it would have been and
right now you really can't you just you
just have to
make all your preparation make all your
calculations be as prudent as you can
and then walk down a path you got to do
it you can't just hem and Hall forever
next question
hi Michael this is one of your based
listeners and I'm based because I'm
Greek Orthodox and because I'm Greek
Orthodox I wanted to ask you your
thoughts again on whether or not animals
go to heaven I know you believe that
they don't as a Catholic but I would
like to reference Revelation 21 5 that
says God will make all things new and I
was wondering if that would have any
role to play in your belief in whether
or not animals go to heaven so I hope
that you change your mind I'd love to
hear your thoughts
I'm sorry my dear Fido does not go to
heaven
Fido does not go to heaven because Fido
does not have a rational Soul Fido has a
soul proper to his nature
but his nature is not rational and his
soul is not Eternal there will be I
suspect animals in the new creation
there will be a new Heaven and a new
Earth
but it won't be Fido I'm sorry to say we
love our pets while they're here and
they provide us all sorts of comfort I'm
told I don't really like pets I'm a
people person as you know but uh no they
don't sorry
sorry as as a friend of mine has said
before
facts don't care about your feelings
facts don't care about your Fido next
question
hi Michael my sister relinquished her
parental rights to my niece who has
extreme special needs she's 13 years old
non-verbal she can only eat formula
she's still in diapers and as she gets
older she becomes more and more immobile
she also has violent tendencies from
time to time
she's cognitively around the age of two
however this kid is the sweetest and
happiest kid in the world and I
absolutely adore her I can't explain how
all that works together but you have to
believe me she's wonderful
my mom is her primary caregiver but I
definitely put in my hours and when my
mom had a medical crisis I became
full-time caregiver to both my niece and
my mom which is incredibly tiring time
consuming and lonely
my problem is that I'm single and I
would just love to be married I'm 38
years old I want my own kids and I worry
that my lifestyle and my life are not
compatible with a relationship
especially a brand new one I just don't
have time for finding and maintaining a
relationship also I work at a Catholic
church and trust me single men my age
who are Catholic are of short supply any
advice
yes on that last point my advice is go
to a traditional Latin mass and you'll
find a lot of
eager young men who are traditional and
quite Orthodox and right-minded and
they'll be a little bit weird a cousin
of mine once described dating in Alaska
said if you're a woman you go to Dayton
Alaska the odds are good but the goods
are odd and that's true that the
traditional Latin mass as well you'll
find great right-minded young men but
you're going to see a lot of bow ties
and a little bit of you know awkwardness
of course you know to to reject the
modern culture in that way the odds are
good but the goods are odd so anyway
that that's a very practical piece of
advice if you want to meet a man and
you're Catholic
as for this difficulty of balancing your
heroic uh loving relationship with your
sister's uh disturbed child and your uh
your personal life
it's very hard and obviously your
personal life is going to take a hit I
wouldn't
uh totally sacrifice that though I you
know I suspect especially if you're in
the modern culture of course you know on
Tinder culture it's going to be very
hard to explain to a man why it's
important to care for your family even
your family that's very developmentally
disabled and you know has all these
problems and why that matters and why
you shouldn't just abort people who you
know you who have any problems or
defects at all but
in your community you know among
traditional catholic christian people uh
that part won't be so hard to explain
you'll just have to be a little more
conscious of it you'll just have to be a
little bit more intentional about how
you spend your time the limits that you
place around caring for this person and
also making sure that you're going on
with your own life as well I I don't
think it's impossible it's just often
when we have great obligations like that
we do really heroic things like you're
doing
sometimes we just put everything else
aside it's very easy to do that and then
we just Sleepwalk through life and end
up in a place one day where we'll regret
having not uh
prioritized other things as well so I
think you've just got to be quite
conscious about it quite intentional
about it and you're going to have to
make more efficient use of your time and
energy than the ordinary person will but
you're doing it for a very good reason
next question
hi Michael I hope you're doing well I
wanted to criticize your Coke and New
Coke analogy of Trump versus DeSantis
provide a more suitable analogy and then
get your thoughts on it sticking with a
soda analogy I think Trump is like going
through the drive through a McDonald's
ordering a Coke but actually getting a
Sprite in 2016 I was very enthusiastic
about his promises of building a much
needed border wall making Mexico pay for
it and draining the swamp unfortunately
he failed to do all three of those
things he was only able to build part of
a wall and we paid for it he did not
dream the swamp by any means in fact he
elevated the biggest swamp monster of
them all Dr fauci into power and allowed
us to stay locked down much past the two
weeks to slow the spread the biggest
quality about Trump's presidency is the
Supreme Court Justices but that wasn't
really anything he personally did any
Republican could have filled those seats
so I'm happy to get the soda at least
but I didn't get what I wanted with the
Santas he's actually distinguishing
himself by making the promise to
actually get the coke you ordered and
the fact that he has a really good track
record and Florida supports that what do
you think of this thanks again and God
bless I disagree with the analysis on
the candidates somewhat it's clear your
you support DeSantis and so what happens
is when one is actively supporting a
candidate in a race one looks at the
rest of the field and
highlights and exaggerates perhaps even
the defects of those candidates and
dismisses or minimizes the the great
achievements clearest example I think is
yeah okay he got Roe v Wade overruled
but you know whatever it's just because
he picked judge anyone would have picked
those judges I don't think anyone would
have picked those judges
I think the George W bush nominated
Harriet Myers for the Supreme Court okay
I think that George H.W bush nominated
David souter for the Supreme Court I
think even Ronald Reagan nominated uh
Sandra Day O'Connor for the Supreme
Court who was kind of squishing a lib
I think that Trump's picks were
particularly good they've got their own
problems too but they were particularly
good especially on this issue
and I think he deserves a lot of credit
for that uh and it's true he failed on
some of his promises some of it he
didn't quite have enough time some of it
uh you know he flubbed himself uh some
of them I think were debatable I mean
the way that he was rearranging trade
deals with Mexico and especially with
China before the covid nonsense uh I
think he deserves more credit for in
terms of you know
this country will pay us you know
whether it's through tariffs whether
it's through renegotiating trade deals
whether you know these are um fungible
complex economic questions but all of
that to say I think my analogy still
holds up regardless of whether you love
Trump or hate Trump I have made clear
I have no intention of endorsing a
candidate in a primary I like these guys
I have interacted personally with all of
the top candidates in the race I love
Trump he's the best president in my
lifetime I think Ron DeSantis is a
terrific governor of Florida and Vivek
is a buddy of mine and we go back to
college together so uh and then I'm even
friends with some of the other
candidates in the race and I'm I I just
it's not that I don't have a dog in this
fight I I do in that I have preferences
of this candidate or that candidate this
quality of this candidate whatever and I
want the GOP to win so yeah I'm all
about that
but I I think I I've got a little bit of
a remove from the people who are
actively campaigning for Trump actively
campaigning for DeSantis or actively
campaigning for someone else the reason
this holds up is everyone knows who
Trump is
you say well I was deceived in 2016.
okay did you vote for him in 2020.
sounds like you probably did I don't
think you voted for Biden so you know
you voted for him in 2020 knowing that
he didn't build as much of the wall as
you hoped and he didn't do this and he
didn't do that so we know who he is
we know and a lot of people didn't
expect him to fulfill all the promises
that we got in 2016. some people such as
myself were shocked we got as much as we
did and yes he he pursued some other
policy it like the jailbreak Bill the
crime thing let the criminals out of
prison I thought that was insane but all
in all it was a great presidency
even if you think all in all it wasn't a
great presidency
there's no ambiguity with Trump
we know who this guy is we've known this
guy for 40 years
you I think you're actually proving my
analogy because you're saying
Trump you're saying old Coke is actually
not that good and New Coke actually
tastes better than old Coke
maybe it does I don't know so it says
I've never tasted a new Coke but maybe
New Coke does taste better that's what
people said in the blind taste test but
I'm telling you 10 out of 10 times every
single time
that someone takes that blindfold off
even if the new Coke tastes better and
you can make a really good rational
logical argument for why the new Coke is
better people are going to want the OG
which is why if DeSantis and he's
starting to do this actually if DeSantis
wants to have any shot at getting the
nomination he's got to run as something
other than the new and improved Donald
Trump because when you put that against
the OG Donald Trump warts and all
people are going to pick the original
we've got a lot of mem of mailbag to get
to the written mailbag we will have to
get to it in the member block okay so if
you remember the white boy over there on
YouTube come on over join dailywire.com
Knowles right now use code nulls at
checkout you get two months free on all
annual plans you can become a member of
the ham and then we can get into
fake headline Friday see you over there
[Music]